hello everyone after the death of
Michael sugar in the very strong chess
club of st. Petersburg decided to
organize a tournament in his honor in
1909 and the st. Petersburg Chess Club
consisted pretty much of only elite
players this tournament the st.
Petersburg great tournament of 1909
consisted of 20 players and the
favourites for winning this tournaments
were definitely cars left her here
emmanuel asked her definitely and the
poly grandmaster Akiba Rubinstein but
we'll get back to that after the game
this game suddenly tapped October is
playing against Karsch Lecter and the
selector was known to be a great
attacker and a fierce player and it's
quite interesting how tartakov
doesn't allow him a chance to attack and
really makes him go for the defense so
let's see the game the attacker has the
white pieces and he plays efore e5 and
Bishop sorry f4 the Kings gambit Bishop
to c5 selector declines the gambit and
well decides not to go for it nice to f3
d6 now f capture son e5 d captures on e5
and c3 preparing d4 Knight to f6 by
Schlichter and I've seen an analysis by
last girl Oscar says that the
sacrificing the e5 pawn is pretty much
justified as the knight won't really
won't really be doing anything on e5 of
course the engine disagrees with this
but what are you gonna do
Oscar said it so Knight captures an e5
by Taco Bell
now selector castles and d4 Bishop to d6
and Knight back to f3 if you were to
defend d4 Knight with Knight - d - for
example then Bishop captures on e5 d
captures on e5 and after Knight to g4
this Knight and g4 is really annoying
annoying for white and you can't really
kick it away from there you know you can
play a move like h3 Queen to h4 is
coming there's really no point in
doubling up your pawns like this you
can't defend with Knight to f3 dis loses
immediately - Queen captures on d1
followed by night to have to check for
king the king and the rook so instead of
all of this after Bishop to b6 Knight to
f3 might a Taco Bell
Knight captures on e4 now winning back
the pawn Bishop to d3 rook to e8
defending the knight and also preparing
some nasty discoveries tough talk over
castles and h6 and again Alaska really
criticized the selector for playing this
h6 move Lasker says that the threat of
Bishop captures knight on e4 and rook
captures followed by Knight to g5 and
Queen to h5 is only imaginary white
doesn't really have this but
interestingly enough h6 is the engines
favorite move so I guess car selector
knew what he was doing
Knight B to d2 and Knight back to f6
Knight to c4 now to harass this very
strong dark square bishop on d6 c5 and
while he played this c5 move it seems
like okay he's challenging the center
but one other thing he's doing if why
doesn't capture this bishop on d6
immediately then Bishop to see c7 might
be an idea which is definitely
definitely worth considering this is a
very powerful piece Knight F to e5 now
biter Taco Bell and this is the critical
moment in the game already unmoved 12
there are a lot of moves for black here
to consider you definitely don't want to
give away this strong bishop
so Bishop to c7 is definitely an idea
rook the e6 okay maybe you do want to
give it up but at least you know get
your rook into the game which rook
captures if the knight captures it but
the worst the worst things like that
could have done is the move he did he
played C captures on d4 and immediately
he allows a tactic or to go to go for
fierce attack and before I show the
attack the move like Bishop to e6
doesn't work because of a very because
of a series of tactical shots Knight
captures on d6 Queen captures and rook
captures on f6
G captures on f6 and our Knights the G
for threatening f6 and h6 and you can't
really defend both of these threats you
can't even capture the night if Bishop
captures 19 Queen captures King to her
fate now Bishop captures on h6 with
check King g7 and now Rob the e1 trick
King b8 rook captures forcing the King
to capture back now Queen to c8 with
check out Queen blocks and now Queen
captures on b7 and black loses the rook
so it's some this is some 8 moves you
have to calculate but it's pretty much
all forced so it's not really a problem
and you can save the rook for example
with Knight to d7 you seem to get Queen
to e4 check and now if you block with
the Queen you'll lose the rook and if
you block with the night
well then D captures on e5 rook to b8
any move black plays doesn't really
matter he captures on f6 would check and
now the black king is getting maded
Queen to f4 check King d6 Bishop f4
check King e6 Queen c6 check Queen
blocks and Queen d6 this is checkmate so
ok this is a lot of moves but it's
pretty much all forced this wouldn't
really be much of an issue for Tata
cover if Bishop to e6 was played so
that's why Bishop d6 doesn't work but ok
selector plate seek address on d4 and
here tartar cover goes for the attack
Knight captures on f7 sacrificing the
night you can't really decline the
sacrifice as your queen is attacked even
if you move the Queen your Bishop is
attacked twice from the knight on f7 and
the night on c4 so you don't have to
capture it
King captures on f7 and now Queen to h5
would check the knight of course can
capture its pinned bringing the King to
the e-file with King g7 or King to e6
wouldn't really be good for black this
this would be quite bad and Electra
played King to g8 and okay this is the
best move and now we have this tricky
move rook captures and f6 by tactic word
and white can't black can't recapture
the rook
if you play Queen captures rook and f6
you simply lose the real Kanye it so you
just lost a knight on f6 this is
terrible for black and if instead of
Queen captures you play G captures on f6
you get Queen to g6 check and after King
to f8 Bishop captures would check King
g7 Queen to h7 check now King e6 Queen
f5 check King f7 and now Knight captures
on d6 getting the Queen to d6 Queen
captures and now Queen to h7 check again
King to e6 and our Bishop the c-4 would
check and black has to give up the Queen
as if the King goes to e5 rook to e1 is
checkmate
so the rook on f6 on f6 cannot be
captured rook to e1 with check by
Schlichter rook the rook to f1 defending
now rook captures and Bishop captures
not team captures you don't want to
allow black together any pieces into the
game with tempo Bishop to f8 as the
bishop was attacked with the knight on
c4 now comes Bishop captures on h6
selector replies with Queen to f6
again capturing the bish capturing the
bishop with G captures on h6 I wouldn't
really achieve much for black Queen to
g6 with check King to h8 now Knight to
e5 and there is no defense against
Knight to f7 you have to play something
Queen to e7 and now Knight to f7 check
this wins the Queen and game over and if
instead of King to h8 you play something
like Bishop to g7 to defend again Knight
to d6 and well but doesn't really have a
move Bishop to c4 is coming for example
any move Knight to a6 Bishop c4 check
King has to move now checking the king
and for King the Queen after the King
moves you don't even have to recapture
you don't even have to capture the Queen
simply an IG 5 or discover check from
the bishop and well now if the King goes
to f8 Queen to f7 is checkmate if the
King goes to h8 Queen to h7 is checkmate
so the bishop can't be captured Queen to
f6 by Schlichter and now Bishop to g5
attacking the Queen Queen to f7 f5
pinning the bishop Knight to d6 offering
now a knight and you don't you don't
really have a choice you do have to you
don't have to capture the night if you
move the Queen you lose the bishop and
c8 also if you move the Queen from the F
file Queen to f7 is an idea so the
knight has to be accepted the bishop
captures on d6 and now comes Bishop to
c4 with Czech Bishop to e6 blocking and
now rook to f1 and you have to give up
the Queen now if we try and defend the
Queen for example with Queen to e5 to
still defend the bishop on e6 this loses
the Queen e8 check and after King to h7
Bishop to d3 check and now there are no
moves for black to g6 simply Queen
captures can get to it and Queen to h7
checkmate
so after rook to f1 okay selector
decided to now give up the Queen Queen
captures an f1 Bishop captures on f1 and
Knight to d7
it seems he might have enough material
for the Queen but not really Bishop to
d3 with ideas of queen h7 or a bishop to
g6 depending on what black plays Knight
to f8 defending both threats and I'll
see captures on d4 grabbing a pawn why
not
Bishop to f7 would attempt on the Queen
Queen to f3 Knight the e6 now Bishop
back to e3 rook the b8 protecting the b7
pawn g4 g 5 and we have Queen to f6
Bishop to f8 black is trying to create
some sort of a fortress but this will be
hard as White has the bishop pair Black
has also the bishop pair but it has a
bishop pair and the Queen Bishop to h7
check now forcing the King to capture
the bishop unfortunately for black King
captures now Bishop Queen captures
Bishop on f7 would check Knight to g7
and we have Bishop captures on g5 and
here cars later resigned the game as he
can't really move any of his pieces this
is very unfortunate if he tries to play
b-52 to be able to get the rook into the
game H for preparing h5 and h6 and if
you try to unpin them simply Bishop to
f6 pinning that night and black doesn't
have any moves to play h5 h6 is coming
this is completely winning for white so
yeah a very nice game by mr. Taco Bell
and well a very nice game by car
selector as well although static over
really had some inspiration this game
and even though he could play a game
like this in the strong st. Louis chess
tournament in 1909 in the end he won
11th place Akiba Rubinstein deposed ran
master won the tournament with 13 and a
half points
Lasker was second also with 13 and a
half points but what some well he had
Robuchon had some better criteria at
additional criteria so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and if any of you
would enjoy maybe a short series of this
tournament the very strong st.
Petersburg tournament of 1909 featuring
Akiba Rubinstein in some of his games do
right
hashtag Rubenstein or hashtag Akiba in
the comments so I don't know if if
people are interested so that's it I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Gilliam I got the air fell coluan
sorry hey : arming the derivates and
Jacob Hartley for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon